[music playing]
FRANCESCA FIORENTINI
(VOICEOVER):
Here in the Japanese
countryside,
some of Japan's most
eligible bachelors
are waiting to meet their mates.
The mayor is here.
Parents are here.
Eligible bachelors and
bachelorettes are here.
FRANCESCA FIORENTINI
(VOICEOVER):
They've even summoned the city's
mascots, the great warrior
Masamitsu and his wife.
[speaking japanese]
FRANCESCA FIORENTINI
(VOICEOVER):
This is one of many
events organized each year
by the Japanese government
to get young people to hook
up, shack up, and make babies.
Japan's overall
population is dropping
and the government is panicked.
Without young people to shore
up the country's tax base,
the coming decades
could see Japan spin
into an economic death spiral.
Emma, a 29-year-old
bachelorette,
traveled two hours
from the city of Tokyo
with the hope of meeting
the farm boy of her dreams.
[speaking japanese]
FRANCESCA FIORENTINI
(VOICEOVER):
Emma has one hour
to play the field,
but comes up empty-handed.
FRANCESCA FIORENTINI: So
what's next for you, Osaka?
Maybe start from
close to where
I live, like Tokyo, maybe.
- Well--
- Yeah.
Well, keep trying.
Yeah.
See ya.